[Music]
I know what they say about
me about hopeless
Romantics that we're
weak and I'm not
weak that learned the hard
way not all love stories have a happy
ending turn up let's pick this back up
next week I just what are you guys doing
here we think you might be a sex edic
every I see you what
[Music]
maybe thir 's the charm this guy don't
stand a
chance haven't been sleeping well
lately I guess I never have this is when
I was little I used to share a room with
my
sister she used to sleep so
peacefully and I just used to lie there
awake
thinking how does anybody sleep that way
when your heart never goes to
sleep I know you feel like nobody gets
you I don't even get me this is me it's
never enough for you he's a liar I've
never lied to you the constant criticism
she thinks I'm her
employee
me being with you feels like home with
but I left home for a
[Music]
reason whenever someone asked me what I
wanted to be when I grew
up my answer was
always in
love you must respect the Ed and flow of
the universe this is me
this is me
[Music]
now